- Thanks to CuriosityStream
for keeping LegalEagle in the air.
Get 26% off CuriosityStream and Nebula
using the link in the description.
Last week, President Trump
issued two executive orders
that will ban two major Chinese apps
from the American market.
The orders state that, in 45 days,
Americans will be prohibited
from carrying out any
transactions with TikTok
and its parent company
and from the app, WeChat.
This means US companies and individuals
will no longer be permitted to
advertise with the platforms,
offer them for download via app stores,
or enter into licensing
agreements with them.
This would effectively stop Americans
from accessing TikTok and WeChat.
The Trump orders came as
a shock to US consumers,
who are generally accustomed
to being able to use
any app that's offered on the app stores
run by Apple or Google.
And complicating this narrative,
President Trump has not
always remained on topic
when discussing the reason for these bans,
which ostensibly is national security.
President Trump also raised
eyebrows by suggesting
that if Microsoft were to purchase TikTok,
thereby saving it from the ban,
they ought to pay the US
Treasury some kind of fee.
- Because I guess it's China, essentially,
but more than anything else,
I said a very substantial
portion of that price
is gonna have to come into the Treasury
of the United States because
we're making it possible
for this deal to happen.
- Wait. What?
Can the president ban a Chinese company
through executive order?
Can the president demand a cut
of the proceeds of that sale?
And what's going to happen
to your second favorite
video sharing platform?
(dramatic music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because the president wants
to ban TikTok, WeChat,
and Tencent and sell them to Microsoft
and get a cut of the sale
like a two-bit gangster.
2020 is really weird.
So let's first start off by talking about
what is TikTok and WeChat.
Now full disclosure, I'm
not on TikTok at the moment.
I tried to use it once,
but I found it baffling and horrifying
so I'm obviously the
best person to explain
what TikTok is, which I'm now going to do.
So TikTok is a social media
app owned by ByteDance,
a tech company based in Beijing.
ByteDance runs a content platform in China
and other areas of the
world known as Toutiao,
which I'm probably
incredibly mispronouncing,
which translates to Headlines.
Originally, Headlines was a
news recommendation engine,
and now it has evolved into
a content delivery platform
reminiscent of Facebook.
ByteDance started TikTok
in 2017 when it purchased
and repurposed social
media startup, Musical.ly
and the two video sharing platforms merged
into a global application
that has gained popularity,
particularly among teenagers
who seemed to ditch social media platforms
just as fast as adults figure
out what to do with them.
Now I asked you on
Twitter, what TikTok was
and your answers were both
illuminating and hilarious.
Joe Vincent said, "A way of communicating
through shared cultural metaphors."
Filip Gunnarsson said,
"The sound of clock makes."
A lot of you said it was
just Vine or Vine 2.0,
which, you know, I get that reference.
Eric Garland said, "It's like Vine,
except instead of just sending movies,
it also sends your
keystrokes on other apps
to the same regime
committing economic espionage
every single day."
Bushra said, "A song by Kesha."
And some weirdo named
Hank Green: A Beautifully
Foolish Endeavor is Out! says,
"It's a creation engine,
providing all the tools,
inspiration, and gratification necessary
all in the same place."
Now, as you probably
know, TikTok's popularity
surged during the pandemic.
The app was downloaded
over 623 million times
during the first six months of
2020, and its biggest markets
were India, Brazil, and the United States,
although it has received a
lot of scrutiny in India.
Which takes us to WeChat,
another one of the companies
that's facing the executive orders.
WeChat is the most used
messaging system in the world,
with more than a billion users.
The app is owned by the
Chinese company, Tencent,
which is a major player in
the US video games industry.
In China, almost 99% of
smartphone users use the app.
WeChat is integrated
with just about every
aspect of a person's life,
from paying for dinner,
applying for a loan,
watching a video, to ordering a rideshare.
Chinese users can do all of that
without ever exiting the WeChat app.
And people in the US and other
countries also use WeChat
to keep in touch with
friends and family in China.
But WeChat has been linked
with Chinese state surveillance
and censorship, and odds are
that if you send a message
to someone using WeChat in China
that's critical of the Chinese government,
then WeChat will block that.
Which takes us to the
social data mining aspects
of both TikTok and WeChat.
TikTok videos are obviously fun, if inane,
but there's also a dark
side to TikTok as well
and the answer lies in the app's ability
to collect information about its users.
When you download TikTok,
you agree to its data collection policies.
In addition to information
you choose to provide,
like your identity and billing info,
the app automatically collects other data.
For example, if you choose to sign up
with your social media,
Instagram, Facebook,
Twitter, or Google accounts,
TikTok reserves the right
to harvest information
from those services,
including your contact list
for these services and
information relating
to your use of the platform
in relation to those services.
And then TikTok also collects
information about you
from third party services
like advertising partners.
And then there are provisions like these,
quote, "Other Users of the Platform.
Sometimes other users of the Platform
may provide us information about you,
including through customer
service inquiries.
Other Sources.
We may collect information about you
from other publicly available sources."
And when it comes to TikTok and WeChat,
the US and other nations are concerned
about the company's relationship
with the Chinese government
and what information TikTok may share.
Although the United States
and other countries trade with China
and corporations do big
business in the country,
the Chinese government is still commanded
by the Chinese Communist Party
and it's not a free society.
Chinese citizens don't
have freedom of speech
and the government controls
the flow of information.
China's 2017 National Intelligence Law
requires Chinese citizens
to support the government's
national security activities,
including possibly aiding the country
in seeking intelligence
from foreign countries
and their citizens.
TikTok's parent company, ByteDance,
has worked with the
Chinese Communist Party
to censor and surveil content
that the government did
not want widely known.
For example, the government crackdown
on any mention of China's
repression of the Uyghurs,
a Turkic-speaking ethnic minority
living mostly in Xinjiang,
which I'm probably mispronouncing.
The Uyghurs are Muslims from central Asia
who are supposed to have
significant autonomy
in the Xinjiang Province.
However, the Chinese government
is arbitrarily arresting
and imprisoning Uyghurs,
censoring their language,
and even erasing social media posts
that mention the Uyghurs by name.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And ByteDance has helped the
government censor information
about the Uyghurs in its
Headlines platform and on TikTok.
Users have reported being
fed nothing but propaganda
when attempting to outwit
the app's algorithm
about the subject.
And naturally, this led to concerns
the company would be willing to share data
about its foreign users
with the Chinese government.
The US Army and Navy
banned service members
from downloading the app to
government-issued phones.
The US House of
Representatives voted to bar
the use of TikTok on all
government-issued phones.
And this isn't necessarily a
politically partisan issue.
The House vote was 336 in
favor to just 71 opposed.
And Chuck Schumer tweeted
his general agreement
with President Trump that
TikTok may hand over data
to the Chinese government.
And Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo said-
- We've urged countries
to become clean countries
so that their citizens'
private information
doesn't end up in the hands of
the Chinese Communist Party.
- And that the app created an opportunity
for the Chinese government
to spy on foreign nationals.
Though just because the app
has banned on government phones
isn't really dispositive of the issue.
Service members are also
prohibited from using Fitbits
after fitness data was used to identify
different military installations
because of the GPS tracking.
But TikTok and ByteDance
have repeatedly denied
ever giving user data to
the Chinese Communist Party.
The company claims that all
of its US data is stored
in data centers in Singapore,
not under the control of Chinese law.
And Kevin Mayer, CEO of TikTok America,
also posted a statement promising
to make its data collection
process transparent.
TikTok also said that the
company has tried to engage
with the US government for over a year,
but that the government
paid no attention to facts.
Although ByteDance has
started talks with Microsoft
about simply selling its US
platform to a tech giant,
the company also vowed to
challenge the executive orders
in the courts.
And we'll get to the executive
orders in just a moment,
but it's probably worthwhile to point out
that there may be significant
First Amendment issues here too
because it's a widely known secret
that President Trump
really hates both TikTok
and the content that's on TikTok.
TikTok is a bastion of
satire of President Trump.
People like Sarah Cooper,
who ridiculed President Trump
by simply repeating what
he has said verbatim.
- You know, TikTok, we
may be banning TikTok.
We may be doing some other things.
There are a couple of options.
- And let's not forget about
all the K-pop stans on TikTok
who signed up for President
Trump's Tulsa rally.
- I got two tickets, but I totally forgot
that I have to pick every
individual piece of lint
off of my room floor.
- And made it appear that
hundreds of thousands of people
were going to show up to
the rally when, really,
only a handful of people did,
which may have led to the ouster
of Trump's campaign
manager, Brad Parscale.
So it's an open question as to whether
First Amendment speech
concerns are one of the reasons
why President Trump wants to
ban these particular apps.
And certainly, eyebrows are raised
when the President bans
particular companies
as opposed to the practice of data sharing
that is the thing that is
ostensibly objectionable here.
But let's talk about the executive orders
that are at issue here that
effectively ban TikTok,
Tencent, and WeChat.
President Trump's executive
orders effectively ban the use
of these apps in the United States.
And to do so, these executive
orders invoke the authority
under the International
Emergency Economic Powers Act,
or IEEPA, and state that
additional steps must be taken
to deal with the, quote,
"national emergency"
posed by these apps.
Traditionally, when
presidents used the IEEPA Act
for national security purposes,
they rely on traditional
issues of national security,
such as access to classified
information on weapons
or intelligence systems.
But President Trump's orders differ
in that they're primarily
targeting companies
because of data security
and data privacy policies.
So what do these executive orders say?
Well let's start with the TikTok
order, which states quote,
"TikTok automatically captures
vast swaths of information
from its users, including internet
and other network activity information
such as location data and
browsing and search histories.
The data collection threatens to allow
the Chinese Communist Party
access to Americans' personal
and proprietary information,
potentially allowing China
to track the locations of federal
employees and contractors,
build dossiers of personal information
for blackmail and conduct
corporate espionage."
As evidenced, the TikTok order says
the company censors content
in line with Chinese
Communist Party guidelines.
The order also says the app could be used
for disinformation campaigns
that benefit the Chinese Communist Party.
The order says that, quote,
"any transaction by any person
with ByteDance or its
subsidiaries, TikTok,
will be prohibited in 45 days."
And this probably means Apple and Google
will no longer be able to list the app
in their respective app stores.
Which takes us to the
other executive order
regarding WeChat.
President Trump's order
on WeChat cited concern
that the app could be used to
spy on Chinese nationalists
who visit or immigrate
to the United States.
The executive order states
that the app allows, quote,
the Chinese Communist Party a mechanism
for keeping tabs on Chinese citizens
who may be enjoying the
benefits of a free society
for the first time in their lives."
The order also hits WeChat
for censoring the same
kind of content as TikTok.
Now the Chinese company,
Tencent, owns WeChat,
but unlike the executive order on TikTok,
which extends to the
parent company, ByteDance,
the order appears not to apply
to subsidiaries of Tencent.
A White House official told
the "Los Angeles Times"
that the band does not apply
to Tencent's subsidiaries
like Riot Games, which is the developer
of the League of Legends game,
which is very popular on the internet.
And Tencent also has a
big stake in Epic Games,
which makes Fortnite, and
the government is clarifying
that those holdings are
not affected by this ban.
But needless to say, if this
order extends to Tencent,
then it would be a major disruption
for the video game industry, but for now,
that crisis appears to have been averted.
But if you came here for the video games,
I'd highly recommend checking
out Richard Hoeg's channel,
who goes into depth about
these executive orders
and their effect on the
video game industry.
I'll put a link to that
down in the description.
But here, both orders
lack specific details.
Both delegate authority
to the commerce secretary
to specify precisely what
transactions are banned
and which might still be allowed.
This means that we have to wait and see
what else the government
says about the orders
in the coming weeks.
So the orders may be broader
or narrower than we think
they are at the moment.
That'll have to be clarified.
But let's talk about the
president's authority
to ban TikTok and WeChat.
TikTok teens are pretty
upset about the government's
potentially taking away a
platform that they love.
So the question is, does the government
have the authority to do so?
Well, the answer is, generally, yes.
And the discussion of those powers
starts with the IEEPA.
President Trump used his powers
under the International
Emergency Economic Power Act
to stop TikTok inside the US.
Now the IEEPA was passed in 1977
actually to restrict
the president's powers
to declare an indefinite
emergency during peacetime.
But as with a lot of legislation
that was intended to be a restriction,
it can sometimes be flipped on its head
and allow the executive broad powers.
The law here allows a president
to take extraordinary action
without consent of Congress,
but it requires the president
to declare a national security emergency
under the National Emergencies Act.
And the IEEPA allows the president
to declare a national emergency
to, quote, "deal with any
unusual or extraordinary threat,
which has its source
outside of the United States
to the national security, foreign policy,
or economy of the United States."
Now those are obviously
extremely broad powers
that give the president discretion
to investigate, block, regulate, compel,
or prohibit the importation, transfer,
or acquisition of property
in which any foreign country
or national thereof has any interest."
The IEEPA's powers allow the president
to act with respect to any person,
quote, "subject to the
jurisdiction of the United States."
And to exercise these broad powers,
the president merely has to
make an initial declaration
of a national security and justify
that declaration to Congress.
And theoretically, initially,
the president had an
ongoing responsibility
to consult with Congress, at
least once every six months,
in order to continue
the national emergency.
And the IEEPA originally gave Congress
the power to stop the president
from using these powers
if, through a concurrent resolution,
Congress declares that
the emergency is over.
However, the 11th Circuit Court of Appeals
held that this provision
was unconstitutional.
Now, if Congress wants to terminate
the president's authority
under an IEEPA decision,
legal experts presume that
it would require passing
a veto-proof joint resolution
terminating the national emergency,
and no such resolution
has ever passed Congress.
And here, the executive orders rely
on a national emergency
declaration made over a year ago
in May of 2019, specifically
Executive Order 13873.
That emergency declaration emphasized
the threat associated with
foreign owned communication
and information technology
companies and services operating
in the United States in circumstances
where the foreign company
is subject to the authority
of a, quote, "foreign adversary."
So in terms of whether it's legal,
the answer is, probably, yes.
As we've seen in a number
of different circumstances,
what we have is broad
delegated powers from Congress,
arguably intended for situations
other than what they're
being used for here,
but Congress hasn't revoked that power.
And when the executive has broad
authority, as it does here,
it's apt to use that broad authority.
Congress has the ability to
revoke that authorization,
but number one, it doesn't appear
that Congress has the appetite to do so,
and number two, it would
need to pass legislation
that would withstand a presidential veto,
which would be a very tall order.
So you can see that Congress
delegated wide latitude
to the president to set policy
using the powers delegated in IEEPA.
And while Congress granted
sweeping powers to the president,
at least Congress did put
some limits on those powers.
So let's talk about some
of those exceptions.
There are exceptions to IEEPA
that might apply to the
president's executive orders.
IEEPA is located at 50 USC Section 1702,
and Subsection B of 1702 states exceptions
to the grant of authority.
And specifically it
says that the authority
granted to the president by this section
does not include the authority to regulate
or prohibit directly or indirectly, one,
any postal, telegraphic, telephonic,
or other personal communication,
which does not involve the
transfer of anything of value.
And then there's Subsection 3
that creates an exception
for the importation,
from any country or the
exportation to any country,
whether commercial or otherwise,
regardless of format or
medium of transmission,
of any information or
informational materials,
including but not limited to,
publications, films, posters,
other forms of media ending with a list
that ends with newswire feeds.
So obviously, TikTok is going to argue
that these exceptions
are directly on point
and prohibit the president
from banning their company
and their practices.
In the first instance,
the first subsection deals
with personal communications,
which TikTok is nothing
if not a way for people to
deliver personal communications
in the form of short videos
to individuals and groups.
And then the third subsection deals
with information transmission,
the newswires and informational materials.
This may apply to the platform itself,
but it also may apply to
the practices of TikTok
of taking the information
of its users and customers
and transmitting it to,
potentially, other places.
So it's possible that
these exceptions may apply.
And if I were TikTok, I
would go before the courts
and I would seek a
temporary restraining order
and, eventually, a permanent injunction
preventing the president's
executive orders
from going into effect.
So now the question is,
can TikTok do anything
to stop these orders?
Does TikTok have any power
to ask for judicial review
of the president's decision?
And the answer there is yes.
The president's declarations under IEEPA
are not specifically exempt
from judicial review.
But keep in mind that the IEEPA
relates to foreign affairs,
and this is an area where the president
has greater discretion
to act without Congress.
The president's authority
over foreign affairs is rooted
in Article II of the Constitution,
which gives the president the ability
to make treaties and appoint ambassadors.
Other clauses also make the
president the commander in chief
of the Army and Navy, with a
whole host of implied powers,
like the authority to
recognize foreign governments
and conduct diplomacy
with other countries.
And as commander in chief,
the president has many powers
involving the collection
of foreign intelligence
and use of military power.
It would definitely not
be an easy case to win.
The Supreme Court has held that IEEPA,
read in conjunction with the
Trading with the Enemy Act,
or TWEA, gives the
president wide discretion
to impose embargoes on products
from foreign countries.
The Supreme Court determined
that the IEEPA was lawfully employed
to impose restrictions on travel
into and trading with Cuba.
Lower federal courts have
also upheld the IEEPA
against First Amendment free speech
and Fifth Amendment
due process challenges.
And it, in fact, appears
that TikTok is filing suit.
NPR is reporting that
TikTok is filing suit
against the Trump administration,
arguing that the US government
conducted no investigation
into the company before levying this ban,
and which would presumably constitute
some sort of due process violation
because they were not
given any kind of rights
before their company
was effectively banned
by executive fiat.
And TikTok is arguing that
it's being singled out,
which seems probably reasonable
under the circumstances.
It seems that TikTok and WeChat
are directly being singled out
as opposed to other potential companies
who are conducting similar
information-gathering practices.
And I'm sure that they're going to argue
that the exceptions to IEEPA apply
and that they fall under the exceptions,
and thus, the president
doesn't even have the power
to issue the executive orders
which purport to ban TikTok.
As that lawsuit is filed and litigated,
we'll see how that turns out.
TikTok's best shot at
overturning the decision
might be challenging it as an attack
on the First Amendment
right of freedom of speech.
Now the complicating factor
is that the government
has gotten way more leeway
to restrict speech since Congress enacted
the US Patriot Act after September 11th.
And many lawsuits involving the IEEPA
and the Trading with the
Enemy Act are also in context
with groups associated
with funding terrorism.
And if TikTok makes a
First Amendment case,
it would need to claim
that the executive order
is not content neutral;
in other words, that the
company would need to claim
that, in order to explicitly discriminate
only against certain types of
speech or certain speakers.
But even that would be an
incredibly uphill battle
because the government would just point
to data collection practices
and sharing practices,
which are likely to be content neutral
in the sense that all of
the data is either shared
or has the possibility of being shared
with the Chinese government.
And the US government would claim
that that gives it a
basis to restrict the apps
and that it's not related
to perceived anti-Trump bias
that is contained in the platforms.
So while there are challenges available,
it seems like the Trump
administration has the ability
to ban these apps.
So the question is, would
a sale of these apps
save them and allow them
to continue to operate?
Before these executive
orders were handed down,
Microsoft indicated that
it would be interested
in acquiring aspects
of TikTok's operations
and allow the app to still be
available to American users.
But it isn't clear whether this deal
could even work at the moment.
Microsoft would only be able to buy
a regional portion of the company,
that part which operates
in the United States.
And the orders would seem to
prohibit Microsoft's TikTok
from having ongoing legal relationships
with TikTok operations
still owned by ByteDance
operating in other countries.
It could also impact licensing deals
for people who make money on TikTok,
who assume that their content
is going to be available
on the other platforms that
are owned by ByteDance.
And the 45-day timeframe
here is very short.
If WeChat or TikTok were
to be saved by a sale,
the transactions would be very complex.
Deals like that will be
done within six weeks,
although the commerce secretary presumably
could extend that deadline.
And here, it looks like
TikTok will probably be sold.
It's an external subsidiary,
so the American operations
are fairly bifurcated
from those operations in China
and the rest of the world.
So it's possible to separate it
and sell it cleanly to
an American company.
But WeChat and Tencent are different.
Those companies primarily operate in China
and there doesn't appear
to be any clear way
to separate their US operations
from the Chinese operations.
And in addition, even if
these companies are sold
to American companies
and continue to operate,
we should all be worried about retaliation
by the Chinese government
and Chinese companies.
China has a much longer history
of nationalizing
companies than the US does
and it's entirely possible
that China is not going
to take this sitting down.
It's possible that China may force
American companies operating in China
to divest from their holdings in China
and sell those holdings
to a Chinese company.
It's possible, as some have speculated,
that China might
retaliate by forcing Apple
to give up all of its
manufacturing arms in China
and sell them to a Chinese company.
We don't know what the
unintended consequences
of these actions are going to be.
And perhaps the strangest legal question
raised by all of these different issues
is whether President Trump can demand
what is effectively a VIG.
What about President Trump's suggestion
that some portion of a sale
could be given to the US Treasury?
- Really the Treasury,
I guess you would say,
of the United States gets a lot of money.
- Yeah, here it appears
that President Trump
was just spitballing like a mob boss,
asking for a VIG from a
local mom and pop bodega.
There doesn't appear to be any law
that would allow the government
to take a percentage of the
funds from the sale of TikTok,
you know, other than, you know, taxes.
That give me a cut mentality of a sale
is literally the kind of thing
that can get a politician
in trouble for commercial bribery.
And that's actually what happened
to Illinois Governor Rod Blagojevich,
who President Trump
pardoned earlier this year.
Now granted, that was in the context
of personal gain for the governor,
not funds going to the Treasury,
but also, any kinds of funds
as a sort of key man cut
from the sale would be so small
in the context of the American government
that one wonders why you would even bother
with such a thing.
But since there's no
evidence or legal ability
for the president to take a percentage
of any sale for himself or the Treasury,
that's probably not something
that we have to worry about for now.
For now.
But I have a lot more to say
about the executive orders,
what's going to happen to TikTok
and the suspiciousness of
the timing of this ban,
but it's probably not safe for YouTube.
And I can't put them on TikTok
because they're longer than 15 seconds,
and also, TikTok might
not exist in a few days,
which is why I put my
extended discussion on Nebula.
Whether it's the government
shutting down your favorite meme factory
or YouTube's algorithm being capricious,
it's hard being a creator
when you don't control the platform,
which is why my creator friends and I
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to
worry about demonetization
or the dreaded algorithm.
It's called Nebula, and we're
thrilled to be partnering
with CuriosityStream.
And President Trump
isn't shutting us down,
yet.
Nebula is a place where creators
can do what they do best, create.
It's a place where we can
both house our content ad-free
and also experiment with original content
and new series that probably
wouldn't work on YouTube.
In fact, if you liked this episode,
the version that I put up on
Nebula removes this ad entirely
and replaces it with
an extended discussion
of President Trump's war against TikTok.
(screen beeps)
This is not something
that started with the
Trump administration.
This goes back before
Obama, back before W. Bush,
before Bush Sr., before Reagan.
And actually, now due to popular demand,
almost all the videos
that I put up on Nebula
are both ad-free and have
an extended discussion.
Nebula features lots of YouTube's
top educational-ish creators,
like our newest additions,
Adam Neely, Charles
Cornell, and Mary Spender.
We're basically
monopolizing music YouTube.
Also, we get to collaborate
in ways that wouldn't work on YouTube,
like Tom Scott's amazing
game show, "Money,"
where he pits a bunch of famous
YouTubers against each other
in psychological experiments
where they can work together
or profit individually.
It's so good.
And I'm working on an original right now
where I explain lots of misunderstandings
about the law called "Bad Law Words Good."
We'll learn important legal concepts
like force majeure, race ipsa loquitur,
and why hot dogs are sandwiches.
It'll be out really soon.
So what does this have to
do with CuriosityStream?
Well as the go-to source
for the best documentaries
on the internet,
they love educational
content and creators.
And we worked out a deal where,
if you sign up for CuriosityStream
with the link in the description,
not only will you get CuriosityStream,
but you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a CuriosityStream member.
And for limited time,
CuriosityStream is offering 26% off
all of their annual plans.
And 26% off is, by contract,
the best deal you will find anywhere.
You're welcome.
That's less than $15 a year
for both CuriosityStream and Nebula.
And since we've got to stay inside,
we might as well be soothed
by the voice of David Attenborough
or join Chris Hadfield on a
road trip through the universe,
or just watch Tom Scott torture
your favorite YouTubers.
So if you click on the
link in the description,
you'll get both CuriosityStream
and Nebula for 26% off,
or you can go to
curiositystream.com/legaleagle.
It's a great way to support the channel
and educational content directly
for just 14.79 per year.
So just click on the
link in the description
or go to curiositystream.com/legaleagle.
And of course, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So what do you think about
the executive orders?
Are they motivated by national
security or political animus?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other Real Law reviews,
including COVID legal issues
and all of the insanity
coming out of the Trump administration.
So click on this video
and I'll see you in court.